most of you probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay she's good
she's strong
justin bieber is praising his wife
hayley bieber following her
hospitalization last week for a blood
clot
[Music]
amid a power outage during his tour stop
in denver the 28 year old singer opens
up about the model's recent health scare
you know it's kind of crazy how life
randomly throws you curveballs you know
we can't really
can't really control
much you know tonight
the power cutting out most of you
probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay
she's good
she's strong
but it's been scary you know last week
haley revealed her hospitalization on
instagram writing quote i started having
stroke-like symptoms and was taken to
the hospital they found i had suffered a
very small blood clot to my brain which
caused a small lack of oxygen but my
body had passed it on its own and i
recovered completely within a few hours
haley describes the experience as
definitely one of the scariest moments
i've ever been through and thanks her
doctors and nurses for their help and it
was a frightening experience for justin
too it's been really scary
but he says he's looking to his faith
and remaining positive i know for a fact
that
god has her in the palm of his hands
and that's a good thing
but tonight i just you know i'm really
grateful to be be here with you guys
just celebrating celebrating life you
know there's
there's a lot of
a lot of horrible things happening in
the earth right now and for us to be in
this room
all together you know laughing smiling
singing songs i mean i can't think of a
better place i would rather be and one
thing's for sure the couple is looking
forward to their future together and
that involves babies i'm excited last
month the source told et that the
biebers are in a great place and believe
a big family is in their destiny
our source says the two both know what
great parents they are going to be
together they both feel like part of
their reason for being on earth was to
be parents
it has been instilled in them since day
one and they are looking forward to
making that happen it's an amazing
feeling and having kids has always been
part of justin's life plan back in 2015
the singer manifested how his life would
look in 10 years
hopefully i have a family
wife some kids
indoor basketball court
and indoor pool
so far he's right on track
[Music]